hey guys welcome back to City skylines
today I'm commentating over one of my
favorites time-lapse is really not that
it matters that much but it's your some
language I figured I'd introduce this
video with very shortly because I'm
going to work on a new town on the
outskirts or pretty far away actually
from the large city in this map and it's
also a little bit smaller than the town
which I built before the last time I
built that is which means that I can
actually do nearly the entire of making
this town in one 20-minute video which
is pretty cool and 120 120 minute video
that is without any of the chores of
having to make farms or any of the
boring filler parts and the majority of
this video is just going to be just
about laying out the town and the direct
area around it and some smaller parts of
it although at the end of this video
I'll also very shortly go into adding
some flower fields on the outside of the
town just because it's something that's
pretty damn Dutch and I wanted to try
and mess around with it it's actually
pretty fitting for this time of year too
but yeah to basically talk about the
town it's located around this very small
regional highway over here which I more
or less needed in this case given how
many cars there will be coming and going
to this town and given that it's a
pretty important connection between two
highways that I have at the moment as
well but it's light from that there will
basically just be one entrance road to
the town so it is going to be pretty
traffic Jemmy at some point in the
future but I just figured this would be
the most realistic way of doing it
looking from a well realistic touch
perspective really and I also just
wanted to try that
quick intersection there with the
asymmetrical ramps and have this small
area as you come into the town where
there's still a bit of commercial and
retail and industrial buildings before
you actually get into the town itself
which is a little bit further down the
road where I can keep the town more or
less mostly clean of the industrial
zones and just keep it to just row
houses and a very small town centre
which turn out to be one of my favorites
but it's also something that I'll get
back to in the next episode actually to
add extra detailing to it the general
area is very heavily inspired by the
general area in Noyd brahmins which is
the area in the netherlands where like
all of the different rivers go and
there's a bunch of different rivers and
all sorts of islands between them and
it's a pretty swampy area and it's just
an area which I took quite some
inspiration for from for this city and
most of all I took inspiration from a
town called Alba which is really random
just I figured the town which would work
alongside the river over here but also
the area around it is what I took a lot
of inspiration from so there's quite a
lot of rivers in this part of the map in
City skylines as well and I wanted to
also keep it quite open so I wanted to
have some large floodplains alongside
the rivers which is an interesting thing
to talk about I did get some comments in
some of my videos too about the fact
that I should probably keep in mind more
of the waterworks in the Netherlands and
some of the things that are done to at
least make sure that rivers don't flood
and things like that and most
importantly what I really wanted to get
in here are some flood plains just some
larger grassy areas alongside the rivers
of more or less flat land where the
river can at least flood if the water
levels really high but not flood the
city so basically those flood plains
will just be kept mostly empty without
any buildings except for some grassy
plains for cattle and things like that
and some football fields because I did
find that quite often the food plains
are actually littered with football
fields so I guess people don't really
care about football that much and I
figured I could also just have the local
Football Club of this town in the
floodplains as well and I also wanted to
get the two dykes because historically
there are two dykes around rivers
there's the I think I got that right and
I don't know if that's a good literal
translation but there's the summer Dyke
which is the very small one which is
right next to the river then you have
the sort of flood plain ish flat area
and then you have another dike which is
supposedly the winter Dyke I really hope
I didn't actually mess the two up there
which is the larger dike which actually
saves the rest of the land from flooding
and that's just something that I quickly
wanted to get in here though there are
some other things as well there are some
designated areas in the Netherlands like
some Potter's that are meant to be
flooded in case that the water level
rises so high that there's high flood
risks in very densely populated areas so
people have just decided to then break
the dikes in less populated areas and
just let those people be [ __ ] just
because if they didn't do that then more
people would be [ __ ] so it's very
utila stick in that way which is
something which I might also think about
but it's definitely not really a big
concern I just wanted to make sure that
the river banks around here would look
sort of well resembling the Dutch
riverbanks as you see alongside this
area which I made it inspired by so to
actually go into the town itself it's
the idea for the town is more or less
that I have these lines these straight
roads which cut straight through this
peninsula that this town is really
located on so there are these horizontal
roads which are all running in a
parallel way through this peninsula and
I wanted to fill in the town sort of
in-between these roads so hence also why
it has that bit of a square-ish shape
and also I wanted to keep in mind is
that it has sort of grown in very small
developments over time so you can see
the houses on the right are really very
new and I'm not going to really even add
too much foliage alongside them there's
also that small little English villa
kind of Street with just a couple of new
houses around it and then as you go to
the left of your screen at the moment
I'm not entirely sure if that's north
south east or west the houses get well
pretty much gradually order and you come
closer to the centre of the city and
this is also more or less reflected in
the layout
of the town where this part is still
somewhat old I would have thought just
about 70s 80s with some houses around it
but the majority of this sort of more
Square and simple layout is really some
of those although 50s 60s types of Red
Roof houses which you commonly see in
neighborhoods like that and then the
center of the city is going to have less
straight and grid like roads and just be
a small old center of the city with old
houses and some more curvy roads here
and there so yeah I did try to get some
degree of having different neighborhoods
we're not just different housing styles
but also different road layouts within
this small town but of course not
make the different neighborhoods too
large because I would like the time to
actually have grown just by little
segments over time so yeah that's more
or less the plan for this town now this
actually leaves me a bit of time as I'm
just doing the standard sort of Red Roof
row houses as you see them in
neighborhoods like this all the time to
actually get back to what I wanted to
talk about in this commentary because
truth be told I didn't actually prepared
this commentary as much as I usually do
I didn't make a topic list for this I
just sort of watched the time-lapse and
opened up the comment section of my last
City skylines video because I didn't
quite get as much time or barely any
time to reply to comments as I usually
want to do I do try to reply to more
comments at least than what I've usually
at least as then what I've done in
episode 19 where I barely reply to
anything but there are still some things
that I definitely want to address there
were many people worrying about how much
I critique my stuff it's been that way
for very long time and I should probably
do something about it by now but I do
want to say about the city that I
definitely don't think it's bad myself
and I'm really happy with how it turned
out I just think I can do better
not just because I've learned but also
because new assets have come out and
it's simply not they're simply not
compatible with this file it's still got
traffic plus plus which I need to use
find Road Heights and all sorts of
old things where there's so much more
new stuff that I want to try and just is
more fun for me so I really just want to
start something new
sometime soon and that's that though I
still have this episode the next episode
in episode 22 but that's all I have at
the moment I'm probably still gonna
record one more episode of wrapping
stuff up a little bit and another video
which I got many comments asking about
of whether I would actually show off the
city in a sort of cinematic way or make
an overview of the city in any way and I
definitely do want to do it I want to
make a cinematic shots video not really
go over the city myself and explain
things this is also something I might do
but like my final video I would love to
make a more cinematic video just with
music just showing off the best shots of
the city and if I still want to give a
small overview of the city with my
thoughts and commentate it I think I'll
just do that in episode 23 as it's sort
of more or less ramped up to a somewhat
finished States that I can still go over
the entire city show what it looks like
all together and what the ideas behind
things are so though I'll definitely
still get back to that and wrap up thus
it wrap up the city in a nice way
because I definitely don't want to leave
it hanging but I'm not ending the series
in the middle of it at least I don't
feel like I should I just want to wrap
it up nicely and move on to something
that truth be told I just want to try a
little bit more I've also taken quite a
break from city skylines and haven't
really done much in it lately and I'm
just really looking for inspirations and
almost the idea that I really want to
play it myself again we just truth be
told I'm not recording videos just to
record videos but the most important
thing to me still is that I just played
for fun obviously and I'm not going to
really play it if I don't have any good
ideas or
well then the need the urge to really
play it so yeah that's really all about
that so I'll definitely get back to this
series I'm not going to leave it just
bleed to death but I do want to get into
some other stuff it's basically also a
tldr version of what I've said in the
last video and also though what I didn't
say in the last video I did say that I
would try some new stuff but I got a
number of comments actually if I would
do something similar to Doha in Qatar
and it was really funny because that's
one of the things that I am actually
planning I would love to make an
economic city like Tunisia is making or
some of the newer neighborhoods in Doha
or Dubai things like that is just
something that I would want to try it's
not necessarily that I'm a huge fan of
them in real life it's just something
that I haven't really seen in City
skylines yet and I feel what should be
pretty feasible but I also might just
make a small skiing town or a new Dutch
town at some point in the future but
I'll just I still can't really say too
much about it just because I still have
to decide on what I'm going to do and I
still want to wrap this up so yeah those
are all the plans for that and now back
to the city for a little bit I wanted to
have another neighborhood over here
which is really one of those 70s 80s
cauliflower type neighborhoods it's
nothing really too special and it's a
really small cauliflower if anything but
it's just something which I figured
would be a realistic addition to the
city and then well to the top of the
screen underneath crushed Derby in this
case I have the like the older part of
the town which is mostly one-stop
shopping streets with two smaller
streets on the side which I'll still get
back to and add more detailing to but
this was really the sort of core layouts
that I wanted to make in this episode to
at least know how I would go about
laying it out and how it all fits with
the rest of the town here
so yeah that's everything when it comes
to that now in general the approach to
making this town is very similar to the
last one I made it's just a different
shape and different size in just
generally a slightly different town and
much like the center of the city also I
wanted to have some actual brick roads
instead of just having what some of
these awkward streets one of the things
also I find is that the streets in the
game are very American like they're
really based on American suburb type
roads or grid type roads I don't really
have these shopping streets as you very
usually see them in Europe there aren't
really any streets with very narrow
street parts and very wide sidewalks or
things like that and it's definitely
something that I try to overcome by just
putting these textures on them and it's
also something that I know some of the
models are actually working on but at
the moment it's not in the game yet so
something to work around basically but
it's one of those yeah just one of those
issues that I wanted to keep in mind and
one of the reasons why I really want to
use these textures because I feel like
if I use the roads the way they are
right now it would not look as European
and as much of a small city centre as I
would like it to be so the next thing I
want to add around here is some houses
alongside the dike and also add some
simple footage on the floodplains and
the dike as well it's not something that
I really had any idea behind I just
looked at many of them in real life and
figured I generally just wanted to have
some trees alongside the road on the
dike and a couple of trees in the
floodplains and at least make them look
a little bit more interesting than just
empty grass with some grass patches this
is also something that I may want to
like come back to when I start a new
city because one of the reasons that I
feel I could do something better than
the city I have at the moment aside from
trying to not voice crack in my videos
is that the city's really built as a
sort of large-scale model
area but it's not so much focused on the
smaller scene so I
to get into decorating certain fields
with grass patches and small flowers
because it's more about the grander
scheme of things and this is actually
something I would like to perhaps not do
in the next city but really focus on
really small details rather than trying
to get a really large sort of realistic
area going because what I sort of feel I
lack in this city not necessarily
everywhere but in general I would like
to do more is focus on the smaller
scenes and making those picturesque
areas which is something that I didn't
get as in as much and you can probably
tell by the time-lapse as well since I
build a lot of things from a large from
a far away aerial perspective rather
than zooming out to get every single
detail perfectly it's more designed from
well yeah an aerial perspective in
general then trying to make it look good
in the details and from the ground up
which doesn't mean that I try to make
the city look like one of these top-down
design cities because that's definitely
not something that I like doing but I
try to get a large scale and I might
want to make these scale a bit smaller
for future cities just so I can put more
effort into detailing so yeah that's
just not suited me I wanted to say as
well oh and I also wanted to have a
quick Cemetery even though it's just a
really simple one over here and a quick
small Hospital alongside the side of the
town because I just felt that would fit
and I well practically also really
needed one as well so these are going to
not be the farm fields but some of the
flower fields which turned out to be one
of the worst ideas I've ever had and I
still don't know why exactly I did it
but it was basically um ah pretty long
and painful time of getting flowers to
be in an exact straight line I also
don't have an auto clicker or a way to
get my mouse to get straight so this was
just this just took a lot of patience
and you can probably see to some of
these lines are just slightly not really
great generally see how that's something
that I might want to say about it too
now to actually return to a couple of
comments actually there was also one
comment which was quite funny saying you
cannot stop this series before
you have in airports well I can really
but maybe I won't I've been saying that
I would add an airport to this town for
quite a while now and I think a very
small regional airport like I'm not
going to go into anything big I'm not
going to go into anything like a
National Airport but just the small
airport as you see around areas like
this just for um well not really flights
for passengers but just for the sport of
it is something that I might want to get
into and just build a very small airport
over here but as much as I would like to
do so I'm not going to build a huge
Airport I think that's just something
more realistically left for a different
theme and for a different City at some
point in the future I also had multiple
suggestions actually and this has been
going on for a while but I thought it
would be funny to talk about in a video
that so many people asked me to flood
the city and make a cool video of that
because it's the Netherlands I suppose
and it's what's more funny than seeing
the Netherlands be flooded I guess so
yeah I might actually do it and I think
it's actually a pretty cool idea at
least from an interesting perspective
that it's really interesting to see how
it would work of course and that it's
just realistically probably also
something that's stereotypically pretty
known for Holland so I might actually
flood it and get that into the final
cinematic shots just for how cool I hope
the shots will look I don't really have
any great expectations of how it's gonna
look so I'm only going to really feature
it if it's going to be some something
interesting and if I can get it to work
really well but I might actually do it
because it really seems like a finale
and I at least want to try it I
obviously also got many comments asking
if I can share the city and put it up
for download and it's something which
I've been thinking about for a really
long time too it's just something which
I'm not entirely sure if I'll do it
because it'll be an absolutely awful job
to try and get this map to work on other
computers and you'll need many outdated
mods and a ridiculous list of assets and
I didn't update it for the last two
weeks or so so it's also a little
outdated so I'm not entirely sure how
well that's going to work out but I
might do it but keep in mind I'm I might
just not do it not because I want to
keep the fire away from everyone but
just because it's so hard to make it
work and I'd rather not release it then
release it and have most people not even
be able to open it and just get all of
these issues with trying to get it to
work on other people species which is
something that I've had troubles with
with roller coaster tycoon 3 in the past
and I don't really want to repeat but
yeah that's basically it I'm running out
of time Maps so thank you guys for
watching this episode and dewy